hey good humans welcome to season floor
off odd-man-out and this episode is
brought to you by not VPN stick around
after the episode for a special offer
from your VPN and learn how to unlock
Netflix we're traveling abroad but for
now enjoyed the episode what comes to
your mind when you think of introverts
it's awfully awkward soft-spoken
lowliness do you put them in a box based
in biases heard from the media your
peers are just unknown sources as you
play along this episode of odd man out
think of how you pick them we brought
together 7 introverts I am an introvert
I'm an introvert I'm an introvert I am
an introvert I'm an introvert I'm an
introvert I'm an introvert one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the lier survives he or she wins the
entire prize this is odd man out
[Music]
the speeds silence found was really
awkward because I just felt like
everybody was like trying to look into
my soul and like determine if I was a an
introvert or not
oh my god okay physically or the way my
mannerisms are I come off as an
extrovert so ya expect it and I think
it's funny too because you put a bunch
of introverts in a box and expect them
to be like you know taking people out
and it's like nah we're not you don't do
that I think this is very fitting what I
guys like to do my wing is her have free
time for yourselves I like to watch tip
talk take my dog to the dog park stuff
like that for me being introverted is
how I gain my energy and I gain energy
from having a long time and being able
to recharge and focus on getting myself
back to a place where I can interact
with people you know I have your time
I'd like to paint sometimes like go the
beach or hike yeah I really like running
and hiking like spending time in nature
well I looked like watching Netflix and
then I also like writing as well it's
like kind of like my creative outlet I
guess yeah I just like chill at home
watch like YouTube videos what I'm not
doing anything I just kind of want to be
like nobody bothered me you know but he
like knock on my door my strategy going
into the game was just like maybe pick
up on like the way that people were like
standing or like just the way people
held themselves and they came across as
more like confident or more sure of
themselves do you guys prefer like
calling or like texting people taxi I
like that you can think of what you're
gonna say exact where you write on the
note and like and tell me they're gonna
call me I didn't just like alright I'm
in the bathroom I think I did talk a lot
at first because I was trying to just
say something so I wasn't voted off too
early what do you guys think is like the
hardest part
being an introvert meeting new people
I've tried like kind of opening myself
up I've been let's go for like five
years
my only friend is like my friend from
high school so like didn't work out so
well yeah for me like giving speeches
and like public speaking oh my god a
speech yesterday in my class knock oh
hell I just freaked out like for me it's
like in large group settings feeling
overlooked or like not considered since
I'm not immediately like vocal about all
my opinions and stuff so like I'm
thinking about it and like composing my
thoughts and want to say stuff but you
know sometimes in those situations like
everyone talks over and then the moment
goes away I feel like I'm very friendly
and bubbly and that maybe came across as
like outgoing so they may be pinpointed
me for that are we starting you guys
ever done any like the personality test
what was doing is like mommy's backside
I'm an infj yeah okay I think mine is
the same and I'm like The Advocate yeah
I don't know like the letters but its
turbulent mediator I believe it's my
fighting that's like I in PT or
something like that
yeah I'm an IFB I enough p200 yeah well
yet no I don't know what you guys are
talking about I mean I know that might
look suspect but I really don't know
yeah when they started talking about
like I ever I don't know the order I was
seriously clueless so I thought I was
gonna be out once they started doing
that so like what do you guys think you
struggle with the most with being like
an introvert like it's like
misconception yeah cuz like that's what
I'm yeah
no words I would say for me me they just
assume not like I hate people like I've
been told a lot that I seem intimidating
at first since I'm so like reserved and
I have like my shell I like the reason I
brought it up is because like a lot of
people assume like I'm not confident and
like they're like oh usually be a more
outgoing and I'm like I'm really
confident myself like I Know Who I am
but that doesn't mean like I can't be
introverted at the same time just
because you're an introvert doesn't mean
you're like to complete her me yeah
everybody's on a spectrum
so people are in a hundred percent an
introvert or a hundred percent an
extrovert we all have like tendencies of
both because like if you think about it
there are very few things in the world
we're like somebody's a hundred percent
one thing I actually do talk a lot like
with like my close friends like at my
family like I don't shut up but like
outside like social public places I like
a more reserved and what strangers to I
just like don't yeah yeah same like I
feel like I need my energy so I don't
like to give that out too much but I
don't want people like you were saying
to think that like we're boring people
you know cuz we can have fun but it just
depends on who we're with so yeah I feel
that I'm like really emotional though
like with my close friends I like let
all of it out but then with people I'm
not really like close with it's just
like slightly I voted for Alex because I
could see him at a party like having fun
he just kind of had a bubbly personality
to me when I'm like surrounded by other
introverts I'll notice I'll be the ones
that just kind of like step up and talk
more so I think maybe people saw that I
was being like that was a little bit
more comfortable within the group so
they kind of saw that as maybe like an
extrovert
and we'd like to continue
so dating how do you guys go about
dating it's hard I have a girlfriend but
you're both introverts and we're both
really independent we know like when to
give each other space like we know that
it doesn't mean that we don't care or
love each other less it just means like
we need a recharge like we don't have to
constantly talk all the time and like we
both really respect that so it's hard I
need to put myself out there more cuz
I'm like I want to date you know like I
want to find somebody but at the same
time it's just that like meeting up part
and it's just like I don't want to do it
you know like good with like a poached
well I should don't approach people but
like when I get approached I kind of
have about how to like go scene or just
like and I'm like 20 minutes eat before
I'm like sorry I can't thank ya it's
like hate clinginess so like I wouldn't
want to spend time with someone like
every day maybe I don't have time for it
so exactly I like being able to be to
myself and do what I want on my free
time without anybody getting offended of
why I don't want them around you know so
yeah but I'm trying to work on that she
just seemed very calm to me as for most
people now they seem more nervous and
kind of anxious you guys still with like
anxiety or anything do you guys have
like a method for anxiety like how to
calm down like how do you guys recharge
I'm still looking for one okay I have a
really hard time like coming down when
I'm really anxious so it's like hard for
me because I shut down completely like I
can't talk or anything when I'm really
anxious so it's mostly like just me
sitting and like staring at a wall yeah
for me it's like music or just kind of
like deep breathing
yeah same like the way I go to sleep
because I have like insomnia like I
can't go to sleep and so like I'll play
like the meditation music on YouTube and
it kind of just like mellows me out
because I overthink a lot and that's
what keeps me up at night
I look like somebody who like engages
and is social and out there so I thought
in the first round that people would
vote me off just off of the first look
but I was surprised that I stayed so
long reach and last found and losing was
really heartbreaking I was pretty upset
because I thought we had it I thought we
had them all out all I do is talk and
not being able to talk was painful I've
never been so cold in my life I just
want to say I was like very sincere
about my answers like did you feel that
way about introverts like I feel like
there's a lot of misconceptions like I
feel bad yeah yeah I'm 100% on the
extrovert side what I'm an ENFJ my
number one passion is communication and
like meeting people and getting to know
them and that gives me like more energy
than anything like I could spend every
single day with some one of the biggest
misconceptions about being like an
introvert or being extrovert for
introverts you typically think someone
who's anti-social someone who's
generally like very quiet but what it
really means is that we as introverts
just get energy from ourselves like we
need to like if we need some space we
get that from reading a book or you know
watching some Netflix as they were
saying being introduced to me means just
being able to like have a small circle
and being comfortable with that you
don't really need like too many
interactions with a lot of people I came
to this show to kind of represent
another type of introvert I wanted to
represent more extroverted introverts
and show that like it's perfectly fine
that if you don't fit like every single
like if you don't check off every single
trait that an intra Rhodes like supposed
to be okay cool oh yeah do I just get
collected sometimes I'll see another
lady walking down the street wearing a
band I want to say some are they come
but I don't want to be like some random
guy who she might like to be afraid of
on the street just want to talk to her
I'm Muslim I'm Muslim I am Muslim a
Muslim I'm Muslim I'm Muslim one of them
is a liar are you an introvert or an
extrovert what do you think I think are
an introvert
she's quiet around the office anyways
this episode is brought to you by nord
VPN you know to VPN is subtle kind of
okay it's a virtual private network and
in essence it keeps you safe while
you're browsing the web whether it's
here or another country I actually have
my identity stolen in another country
last year did not use a VPN now I do so
check it out go to north VPN comm slash
Jubilee for 70% off you can get an or
VPN for just 349 month and because it's
Nords 8th birthday you're 8 years old
you will also get a special surprise
gift if you sign up for a 3 year
subscription what's this a price good I
don't know I have no idea it's a
surprise one of the big perks that you
would like is that when you go to
another country you can watch the u.s.
content on Netflix or any other
streaming service that's amazing so when
you go home India you can watch the
office fine really well nor VPN can't
help you there but with all the other
continents tone Netflix
yeah check it out that's
okay but please like and subscribe to
the channel and follow us on instagram
is the office really leaving it that's
really sad